[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Christian otto ist auch dabei
für den Sport mit einem Novum in Paris
schönen guten Abend und das sind die
Nachrichten Themen von heute
Angriffe auf herrson während sich
tausende Menschen vor den Fluten in
Sicherheit bringen steht die Stadt unter
russischen Beschuss
Kompromiss Suche in Luxemburg die EU
Innenminister streiten über eine
Verschärfung der asylregeln
und 300 Jahre Johann Sebastian Bach
Leipzig feiert einen der größten
Komponisten der Musikgeschichte
[Musik]
in der Ukraine wird die Lage nach dem
Dammbruch immer schlimmer Betroffene und
Helfer am Fluss nipo sind gleichzeitig
den Wassermassen und neuen
Kriegshandlungen ausgesetzt seit dem
Bruch des kochhofer Dammes Dienstag früh
ist der Fluss um ein Vielfaches
angewachsen hier der Stand von gestern
viele tausend Menschen mussten ihre
Häuser verlassen und mitten in dieser
Katastrophe meldet die Stadt herson
russischen Beschuss Christina gröntgen
berichtet
der Artillerie Bischof beginnt während
der Rettungsarbeiten die Helfer müssen
ihre Arbeit unterbrechen Menschen suchen
Schutz zwischen den Häusern
auch unser Kamerateam muss sich in
Sicherheit bringen
erst wenige Stunden zuvor hat Präsident
selenski hier Anwohner und Einsatzkräfte
getroffen sich ein Bild gemacht von der
Lage im Flutgebiet er hält den großen
vor sich nicht zu kümmern auch Hilfe von
den Vereinten Nationen und dem Roten
Kreuz komme nicht schnell genug
oberhalb der flutgebiete am karowka
Stausee zeigt sich das zweite Gesicht
dieser Katastrophe tausende tote Fische
große Flächen drohen zu veröden
ich denke dass wir nicht in der Lage
sein werden dieses Problem alleine zu
bewältigen wir brauchen Unterstützung
von internationalen Organisationen die
uns helfen mit den Folgen dieser
Katastrophe fertig zu werden
und an der Front wird weiter gekämpft
Russland meldet ukrainische Truppen
hätten versucht in der Region saporicia
vorzustoßen
der Feind wurde gestoppt auf allen vier
Achsen und er hat sich nach schweren
Verlusten zurückgezogen
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht genauso
wenig wie der Vorwurf dass auch die
Ukraine Retter im Flutgebiet beschieße
hier in der Stadt hollapriestern seien
dabei zwei Menschen getötet worden
die Not ist groß auf beiden Seiten des
Flusses 600 Quadratkilometer Land sind
nach ukrainischen Angaben mittlerweile
überschwemmt und das Wasser strömt
weiter ungehindert durch den zerstörten
Damm
Tim Krüger ist weiterhin Herr sonders
heute beschossen wurde Tim was bedeutet
das für die Menschen die dagegen die
Flut kämpfen
also eine dieser Raketen ist heute an
einer Stelle eingeschlagen wo gestern
den ganzen Tag aber auch heute sehr
viele Menschen evakuiert worden sind
also man kann das eigentlich gar nicht
anders bezeichnen als Terror gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung vor allem eben gegen
jene die versuchen irgendwie mit den
Folgen dieses dammbrust mit diesem
Fluten klar zu kommen wir haben hier
gerade eben noch mal mit Hilfskräften
gesprochen die uns gesagt haben das
teilweise die Rettungsaktion dennoch
weitergehen aber natürlich ist mit
dieser Bedrohung von heute die Situation
hier in Herford noch einmal deutlich
schwieriger geworden
in der Region saporicia soll es eine
Offensive der Ukraine gegeben haben was
kannst Du dazu sagen
also die Situation an der Front ist
immer sehr schwer einzuschätzen vor
allem weil die ukrainische Seite sich
mit Informationen sehr bedeckt hält aber
die stellvertretende ukrainische
Verteidigungsministerin hat gesagt das
im Süden des Landes gekämpft wird und
das vor allem in der Region saporizia
die russischen Einheiten ganz offenbar
in der Defensive sein das bedeutet ganz
offenbar dass es Offensivaktion der
Ukraine gibt so wie wir das auch schon
Anfang der Woche gesehen haben ob das
alles jetzt schon zu der erwarteten
gegen Offensive der Ukraine gehört
müssen wir einfach abwarten danke schön
für diese Einschätzung und alles Gute
nach Hassan Tim Krüger war das
wenn sie helfen wollen das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
unterstützt die Menschen auch im
Überschwemmungsgebiet Stichwort ZDF
Nothilfe Ukraine iban.de
65-100 400 600-100 400 600 alle Infos
unter spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text
auf Seite 890
wie umgehen mit Menschen die in die
eu-flüchten bei diesem Dauerstreit
könnte heute beim Innenminister Treffen
in Luxemburg eine Einigung gelingen auf
deutlich scharfere asylregeln die
allerdings sind hoch umstritten es geht
im Kern um eine erste Prüfung schon an
Europas Außengrenzen Migranten mit wenig
Aussicht auf Asyl sollen umgehend
zurückgeschickt werden strittig ist ob
es Ausnahmen für Familien mit Kindern
gibt die große Mehrheit der geflüchteten
etwa aus Syrien oder Afghanistan soll
weiter ein Recht auf ein reguläres
Asylverfahren haben Länder die keine
Migranten aufnehmen müssten einen
Ausgleich zahlen aus Luxemburg Isabel
Schäfers
es sind diese Einzelschicksale
flüchtender Menschen die in ihrer
schieren Masse Europa seit Jahren
herausfordern und genauso lange für
Streit zwischen den EU-Ländern sorgen
werden wir zusammenarbeiten und die
Migrationen zusammen regeln dann
gewinnen wir alle
vor allem Länder an Europas außen
Grenzen wie Italien und Griechenland
fühlen sich vom Rest der EU im Stich
gelassen denn bisher ist die Verteilung
von Flüchtlingen nicht geregelt die neue
asylreform soll Solidarität
verpflichtend machen anerkannte
Asylbewerber sollen umverteilt werden
wer nicht aufnimmt muss zahlen Ungarn
und Polen verweigern das
Meinung nach ist dieser Vorschlag ein
Rückschritt wenn wir gezwungen werden
Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen oder ansonsten
eine Strafe zahlen müssen dann können
wir das unseren Bürgern nicht erklären
und somit auch nicht zustimmen
außerdem soll es künftig sogenannte
grenzverfahren an den Außengrenzen geben
für Flüchtlinge die kaum Chancen auf
Asyl haben über ihre Asylanträge würde
dann besonders schnell in
abgeschlossenen Lagern entschieden
es liegt ein Kompromiss auf dem Tisch
der ist sehr schwierig für uns in
Deutschland ich kämpfe sehr darum dass
wir Familien mit kleinen Kindern nicht
in das grenzverfahren bekommen für uns
als Deutschland stehen die
menschenrechtlichen Standards ganz vorne
und dafür werde ich auch heute hart
kämpfen viele Bedenken viele Kompromisse
doch ein erneutes Scheitern soll umfasst
jeden Preis verhindert werden
könnte das heute noch klappen Isabell
Schäfers
ja das ist die große Frage die Minister
haben hier heute in mehreren Runden
immer wieder über dem Thema Migration
gesessen und auch zur Stunde wird wohl
noch um Details gerungen was man hier
aber in den letzten Stunden schon
raushören konnte ist doch das deutliche
Bestreben heute noch zu einer Einigung
zu kommen jetzt geht es aber noch
konkret etwa um Zahlen wie viele
Flüchtlinge sollen konkret umverteilt
werden wie viel müsste man bezahlen wenn
man keine Flüchtlinge aufnimmt und dann
gibt es natürlich auch noch den
deutschen Vorstoß nämlich Familien mit
Kindern aus diesen grenzverfahren
künftig rauszuhalten und mit diesem
Forschung steht Deutschland sehr sehr
isoliert da und da ist jetzt eben die
Herausforderung wie geht man damit um
weil Deutschland ja auch an dieser
gesamten asylreform ein großes Interesse
hat und deshalb nicht mit Nein stimmen
will also da wird noch gerungen eine
gesichtswarende Lösung für alle zu
finden ein Kompromiss wie immer und wir
warten hier gespannt darauf ob es
wirklich zu einer Einigung kommt und
wenn ja wie die dann am Ende aussieht
danke schön für den Moment nach
Luxemburg Isabel Schäfers
um den Umgang mit geflüchteten ging es
auch in Rom beim Treffen von
Bundeskanzler Scholz mit Italiens
Ministerpräsidentin Meloni beide warnen
warmen für eine gemeinsame europäische
Lösung bereits zuvor hatte Scholz der
Ultra rechten Regierung von Meloni
Solidarität bei der Aufnahme von
Flüchtlingen zugesichert ein weiteres
Gesprächsergebnis ab Herbst soll es
wieder deutsche italienische
Regierungskonsultationen geben
die umstrittene Wahlrechtsreform kann
vorerst in Kraft treten Bundespräsident
Steinmeier hat das entsprechende Gesetz
unterzeichnet es sieht eine
Verkleinerung des Bundestags vor auf
Kosten von ausgleichs- und
Überhangmandaten dadurch führen sich vor
allem CSU und Linke benachteiligt die
Union will vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht klagen
egal ob Auto Laptop oder Waschmaschine
kaum ein Gerät kommt noch ohne
Halbleiter aus jetzt hat die EU grünes
Licht für milliardenschwere Subventionen
gegeben auch Deutschland kann damit vier
Milliarden Euro in 31 Projekte stecken
ziel ist es die Abhängigkeit von den USA
und Asien zu verringern
in Frankreich sorgt ein Messerangriff
auf Kleinkinder für Entsetzen auf einem
Spielplatz in eine sie hat ein syrischer
Flüchtling offenbar gezielt Kinder
attackiert vier schweben in Lebensgefahr
im Alter zwischen 22 Monaten und drei
Jahren auch zwei Erwachsene wurden
verletzt einer davon schwer der
französische Präsident spricht von einem
Akt absoluter Feigheit eine Arend
berichtet
ein alpenort ein ganzes Land schockiert
auf diesem Spielplatz am See von ansie
attackiert ein Mann vier Kleinkinder mit
einem Messer alle befinden sich in einem
gesundheitlich kritischen Zustand
es macht mich sprachlos nie hätte ich
gedacht dass das an so einem schönen und
so friedlichen Ort passieren könnte
ich habe sofort meine Schwiegertochter
angerufen und zu fragen wo mein Enkel
ist von dem Angriff gibt es Handyvideos
die unmittelbar danach hochgeladen
werden diese Bilder sollen den Täter
zeigen mit einem Messer in der Hand
springt er über den Zaun geht auf die
Kinder los das jüngste ist 22 Monate alt
er rennt durch den Park verletzt dabei
zwei Erwachsene dann kann ihn die
Polizei überwältigen
Premierministerin born reist zum Tatort
sie sei erschüttert von der brutalen Tat
in Gedanken vor allem bei den Eltern und
den verletzten Kindern und dann äußert
sie sich zum Profil der Mann Anfang 30
soll sich erst seit kurzem in Frankreich
aufhalten
es ist ein Einzeltäter syrischer
Herkunft mit einem anerkannten
Flüchtlingsstatus den er vor zehn Jahren
in Schweden beantragt hat er hat keine
Vorstrafen er ist in Sicherheitsbehörden
nicht bekannt und man weiß nicht ob er
eine psychische Störung hat
das Motiv bislang unklar ein
terroristischer Hintergrund wird zu
diesem Zeitpunkt ausgeschlossen die
Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt wegen
versuchten Mordes in mehreren Fällen
Thomas Walde ist in eine Sie Thomas wie
geht's den Kindern und was ist noch über
den Hintergrund des Täters bekannt
vier Kinder schweben noch in
Lebensgefahr sind in absolut kritischem
Zustand drei werden hier in Kliniken in
an sie behandelt eines in Genf in der
Schweiz weitere Kinder werden
medizinisch betreut sie waren
Augenzeugen und sind schwer schockiert
zum möglichen Motiv des Täters haben die
Behörden ein bisschen lang keine Angaben
gemacht laut Medienberichten habe der
Mann sich als syrischer Christ
ausgewiesen selbst bezeichnet
Premierministerin bauen sagte hier heute
in anzieh Design nicht der Tag für
politische Schlussfolgerungen die
Opposition zeigt nicht so viel
Zurückhaltung das Restaurant national
von Marine Le Pen hat umgehen
französische Migrationspolitik und
europäisches Asylrecht kritisiert
dankeschön
bei einem Brand in einem Tiroler
Bahntunnel sind mehr als 33 Reisende
leicht verletzt worden sie waren in
einem Nachtzug der Österreichischen
Bundesbahnen unterwegs von Wien nach
Hamburg und Amsterdam der Zug passierte
den taffnertunnel bei Innsbruck als zwei
transportierte Autos in Brand gerieten
und 150 Menschen wurden in Sicherheit
gebracht offenbar war eine Oberleitung
auf die Autos gefallen und hatte das
Feuer ausgelöst
seit Wochen kämpft Kanada gegen große
Waldbrände der Rauch der Feuer hat jetzt
auch an der Ostküste der USA Alarm
ausgelöst im Großraum New York in Teilen
new Jerseys und Pennsylvanias erreicht
die Luftverschmutzung gefährlich hohe
Werte die Behörden warnten die Menschen
davor sich im Freien aufzuhalten und
wenn dann nur mit Maske auch in der
Hauptstadt Washington ist die Sicht
ziemlich eingetrübt
hören Sie mal das kennen sie alle
[Musik]
das ist nur einer der vielen Klassiker
von Bach am 8 juni vor genau 300 Jahren
begann Johann Sebastian Bach in Leipzig
als Kantor des dortigen Thomanerchores
dort schuf er zahlreiche Werke die noch
heute mit Hingabe gehört und gespielt
werden besonders begeistert gerade vor
Ort auf dem Bachfest Franziska
wunderlich
[Musik]
was hier klingt er San Johann Sebastian
Bach vor 300 Jahren und empfahl sich
damit als neuer Thomas Kantor der Stadt
Leipzig
ist die Kantate die Johann Sebastian
Bach zu seinem Amtsantritt im Jahr 1723
als erstes musiziert hat in der
Thomaskirche also das war die erste
Musik die als Thomas Kantor aufgeführt
hat dieses Jubiläum aber vor allem Bachs
musikalisches Erbe wird von der Stadt in
den nächsten 10 Tagen gefeiert denn was
er schuf beeinflusste und bewegte
Generationen über Jahrhunderte und
sämtliche Kontinente hinweg
wenn Sie heute Musiker und zwar nicht
nur aus der Klassik fragen würden
sondern vielleicht auch aus dem Jazz
oder aus dem Rock und Pop die würden
alle sagen Bach das ist sozusagen unser
aller Meister ein Meister der weit mehr
als 1.000 Kompositionen hinterließ
Kompositionen die sich bis heute sogar
Rock und Popstars zu eigen machen rapper
Eminem ist da nur ein Beispiel
[Musik]
leipzig bietet die Bühne für Bach in all
seinen Facetten von klassisch bis neu
interpretiert das ist ein riesen Magnet
wir sind damit im Grunde genommen dass
das Mecca Johann Sebastian Bachs und all
die Pilger die Bach Jana die einmal in
ihrem Leben zu Bach Pickern wollen naja
den muss man im Grunde genommen nicht
erklären dass da die Reise in Leipzig
endet im vergangenen Jahr pilgerten
bachfans aus 50 Nationen nach Leipzig
ein Rekord der in diesem Jahr noch
gebrochen werden soll
schöne Schlussakkord aber noch sind wir
nicht am Schluss erstmal zum Sport und
einem lang ersehnten 58 Jahre ist schon
eine lange Wartezeit West Ham United
bejubelt erstmalig seit 1965 wieder
einen internationalen Titel der Londoner
Club mit dem deutschen Nationalspieler
Tilo Kehre gewann das Endspiel der
Konferenz liegt gegen AC Florenz mit
zwei zu eins
das Warten hat ein Ende Konfetti für
West Ham United und natürlich der
Europapokal schon als das Siegtor viel
waren sie nicht mehr zu halten in der 90
Minute machte Jared Bowen mit dem 2:1
Siegtreffer den Europapokal sie klar
alle auch die Fans in Prag flippen aus
euphorisch nach 58 Jahren ohne
internationalen Titel
westham ging in der 62 Minute nach Hand
Elfmeter in Führung Sahid benrama
verwandelte sicher nur sechs Minuten
später der Ausgleich von Florenz durch
Giacomo Bonaventura beide Fanlager
randalierten vor und nach dem Spiel in
Prag Ergebnis sechs Verletzte für die
UEFA war die Partien Hochrisiko Spiel
die meisten aber feierten einfach
friedlich
Pokalsieger Timo Werner fällt
wahrscheinlich wegen einer
knöchelklausur im ersten der drei
bevorstehenden Länderspiele am Montag
gegen die Ukraine in Bremen aus seine
Teamkollegen absolvierten am Nachmittag
auf dem DFB Campus in Frankfurt am Main
dagegen das erste gemeinsame Training
für das auch 600 Zuschauer zugelassen
waren
Tim Pütz aus Frankfurt ist als erster
deutscher Tennisspieler Grand Slam
Gewinner in Mix Doppel bei den French
Open Paris gewann er mit der Japanerin
Kato gegen Wien es an Wesco aus
Neuseeland Kanada in drei Sätzen und
auch für Alexander das Finale immer
näher
ein Schrei der Erleichterung der jedoch
auch zeigt wohin die Reise gehen soll
klar ich freue mich im Halbfinale zu
sein das tut jeder der ein Grand Slam
Halbfinale erreicht hat aber damit ist
das Turnier für mich noch nicht beendet
der Schlüssel zum Erfolg gegen den
Argentinier Thomas Martin
ätscheveri eine taktische Anpassung nach
dem verlorenen zweiten satzwechsel in
den Angriffsmodus und diesem verdankt er
den Sieg in vier hart und kämpften
Sätzen jetzt wartet Kasper Rüth aus
Norwegen im Halbfinale
[Applaus]
ist hier im Vorjahr und bei den US Open
ist wieder wie man sich erfolgreich
wehrt
und deshalb Finale morgen Nachmittag
nicht vor 5:30 Uhr gut dann ist das auch
geklärt vielen Dank Christin heute hat
es vor allem in der Mitte Deutschlands
ganz schön geschüttet und gekracht wie
hier bei Nürnberg kam es zu Starkregen
und Hagelschauern viele Straßen wurden
in kürzester Zeit überflutet einige
Unterführungen liefen voll zum Leidwesen
der Autofahrer und aktuell waren der
Deutsche Wetterdienst vor schweren
Gewittern in Teilen Bayerns die Nacht
wird dann erstmal ruhiger die meisten
sonnigen Aussichten für morgen hat
gleich Katja Hornbach
begrüßt sie um 9:45 Journal und wir
danken für Ihr Interesse und wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auch wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute brodelt es in der
Atmosphäre es gab kräftige schaue und
Gewitter das ging schon am Vormittag los
hier in Sachsen aber auch in Thüringen
rund um die Mittelgebirge auch in Bayern
und in Baden-Württemberg viele von uns
hatten aber auch einfach wieder nur viel
Sonnenschein so stiegen die Temperaturen
z.B Berlin Eiskeller auf
31,8 Grad schauen Gewitter begleiten uns
noch in die Nacht aber in der Nacht
lassen sie mehr und mehr nach es ist
dann häufig klar und die Temperaturen
sinken auf 15 Grad am Niederrhein und
bis 6 Grad in Schleswig-Holstein und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen an
der Küste bei 19 bis 25 Grad im
Binnenland werden es aber meist
sommerliche 24 bis 30 Grad am Vormittag
strahlt die Sonne vielleicht im Südosten
gibt's schon die ersten Quellwolken aus
denen entwickeln sich danach nachmittags
hier und da einzelne Schauer und
Gewitter in Sachsen im Bayerischen Wald
vielleicht auch mal in der Eifel oder im
Schwarzwald bei einem Wind aus
ärztlichen Richtung und an diesem Wetter
wird sich auch in den nächsten Tagen nur
wenig ändern es bleibt beim Ostwind bei
viel Sonnenschein und bei Temperaturen
zwischen 20 und 31 Grad guten Abend